bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce 7 8 le journal voici les titres
l'hiver frappe très fort cette année
avec des températures négatives nous
nous sommes rendus sur le marché de
maurepas pour voir comment les clients
et les vendeurs s'adapter à ces
conditions
2017 sera politique présidentielle
législatives mais aussi sénatoriales les
enjeux au cours de cette édition noël
est terminée place au bilan pour les
fabricants de jouets
nous sommes allés à la rencontre des
dirigeants de l'entreprise de jeux à ce
mode est basée à saint quentin en
yvelines pour savoir comment s'était
déroulée cette période on débute ce
journal avec la vague de froid qui sévit
en france depuis plusieurs jours
face à ces températures négatives
bonnets écharpes sont de rigueur sur les
marchés clients et vendeurs s'adaptent à
cette fraîcheur hivernale s'habiller
pour résister au froid
pierre leroy a fait le choix d'une
triple épaisseur ce vendeur de fruits et
légumes pense aussi à la protection de
ses produits tout ce qu'il veut être
principalement salade d'endives les
produits plus fragiles qui sont gorgés
d'eau et puis après d'autres produits
vont résister très bien - 2 - 3 mais
après il faut sortir les produits au
dernier moment pourquoi qui prennent un
coup de froid sur ce marché la
fréquentation est en baisse durant
l'hiver mais des habitués bravent le
froid pour faire leurs courses
je m'habille très chaud avec casquettes
étaient restées et est double
chaussettes
je viens régulièrement tous les
mercredis tous les samedis je me couvre
plus chaudes non effectivement c'est
tout après les fêtes de fin d'année les
ventes sont relativement calme au niveau
des poissons et des fruits mer en cause
l'arrêt des pêches pendant une semaine
après le nouvel an pour les marchandises
proposées la conservation des produits
est adapté aux températures hivernales
la petite technique en hiver pour
utiliser moins de glace on rajoute tout
simplement un ou deux couvercles en
polystyrène en plus pour éviter
d'utiliser trop de glace alors qu'on
était en en mai le strict minimum pour
pouvoir remplir le bac quasiment
entièrement glace
pour l'habillement non plus de couches
pas forcément meilleure qualité des
baisers vêtements beaucoup plus chaud
parce qu'il ya beaucoup plus de vent ou
et les températures sont inférieures à
zéro s'applique un petit peu capuche
bonnets écharpes et tricot sont de
sortie et pour les plus courageux il n'y
a pas de secret rester en mouvement est
le meilleur moyen pour conserver sa
chaleur corporelle et le début de
l'année est souvent marquée par le veut
les voeux des élus vendredi dernier
alexandra rosetti maire de
voisins-le-bretonneux s'est prêté à
l'exercice
au centre sportif des pyramides pour ce
premier bilan de mi mandat
l'équipe municipale annonce avoir
réalisé près de 80% des actions prévues
dans son programme
on a beaucoup travaillé sur la
sécurisation de nos écoles de nos
crèches donc là dessus on a on a fait
pas mal d'investissements et ça va se
poursuivre on a un plan de déploiement
de caméras
trois ans qu'on fait en concordance avec
la police nationale
la hausse d'impôt elles concernent la
partie départementale
je le dis parce qu'à voisins on a un
petit peu des ces motos justement alors
ça ne compense pas évidemment là où du
département mais quand même on a fait
l'effort en particulier sur la taxe
d'enlèvement des ordures ménagères
d'amorcer une baisse en près de lille 17
jeux prévoit une stabilisation
ce qui est déjà de toute façon à chaque
fois à bel effort le maire de bois
d'arcy philippe benassaya a lui aussi
présenté ses voeux la semaine dernière
plus de 500 personnes étaient présentes
pour l'occasion à mi mandat c'est une
année importante pour le maire avec
notamment le départ de la course paris
nice cette année à bois d'arcy
alors l'année à venir c'est beaucoup de
projets en matière sportif avec la
rénovation de notre gymnase principal de
cause ex est aussi là la livraison de la
piste d'athlétisme c'est aussi des
circulations douces vers saint quentin
en yvelines
c'est aussi l'inauguration du micro
crèche est aussi une maison de quartier
une mairie annexe ont envoyé beaucoup de
choses cette année on est en plein
milieu du mandat et c'est là où on est
en train de finaliser tous les projets
qu'on avait promis lorsque nous avons
été élus en 2014 on est fiers très
heureux d'avoir le paris-nice et c'est
un immense honneur que de donner le
départ à bois d'arcy du de cette fameuse
course qui est une des plus célèbres
avec le tour de france donc ça va être
là aussi le moment de faire la fête et
et ça va être un grand moment fédérateur
et populaire un bonheur si 2010 est
serait une année hautement politique
plusieurs dates sont à prévoir
tour d'horizon avec wilfrid riches de
janvier à septembre le calendrier
politique français sera rythmée par
plusieurs scrutins pas moins de trois
élections nationales prévues en 2017 et
le 23 avril les électeurs se rendront
aux urnes pour désigner leur nouveau
président de la république
si françois hollande a fait le choix de
ne pas briguer un nouveau mandat les
prétendants sont nombreux
sont d'ores et déjà en compétition le
candidat des républicains françois
fillon jean luc mélenchon sous les
couleurs de son mouvement la france
insoumise emmanuel macron pour le
mouvement en marche ou encore marine le
pen pour le front national
pour le parti socialiste il faudra
attendre le résultat de la primaire
second tour le 29 janvier sept candidats
à départager et parmi eux le député
blinois benoît hamon
l'ancien ministre de l'éducation
ministre de l'économie sociale et
solidaire est aujourd'hui présenté comme
un rival sérieux à manuel valls et
arnaud montebourg
à noter que pour le scrutin quelques
7530 bureaux de vote seront ouverts dans
l'hexagone un site internet a été lancé
pour trouver celui situé le plus près de
chez soi
aussitôt la présidentielle terminé il
faudra passer à la désignation des
députés l'assemblée sortante est composé
de 313 députés de la majorité
présidentielle
232 la droite parlementaire onze
d'europe écologie les verts 9 du front
de gauche et deux du front national dans
les yvelines la gauche ne détient que 2
des 12 circonscriptions de
circonscription qu'il sera difficile de
conserver au regard du contexte national
pourtant l'enjeu est de taille pour le
ps qui a déjà perdu l'intégralité de ses
représentants lors des dernières
élections au conseil départemental
les français ne se rendront pas
directement aux urnes mais leurs
représentants au sénat vont aussi changé
pour cent soixante dix d'entre eux et
notamment pour ceux de l'île de france
un renouvellement par moitié peau une
chambre actuellement acquise à la droite
la droite dispose en cette fin de
mandature de 4 des 6 sièges du
département sport culture enseignement
supérieur action sociale quelles seront
les compétences de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines demain composé
de douze communes depuis un an le
nouveau territoire n'a pas encore défini
l'intégralité de ses missions il ne
reste que jusqu'à décembre pour les élus
afin de se mettre d'accord passé cette
date la loi prévoit tout simplement que
l'intégralité des pouvoirs soit exercée
par l'agglomération aux dépens des
villes aujourd'hui élus de la majorité
et de l'opposition ne parviennent
toujours pas à s'entendre et puis sur un
plan international 2017 sera aussi
l'année des 60 ans du traité de rome le
25 mars l'europe célébrera un texte qui
dans son préambule aspirait à établir
une union sans cesse plus étroite entre
les peuples européens
six décennies plus tard l'union
européenne et pour ton secoué par une
importante crise identitaire et
politique
le rock était à l'honneur à la salle de
la torah voisins le bretonneux 45
musiciens amateurs ont repris des titres
de rock français et internationaux pour
cet événement organisé par l'association
multisons et le moins que l'on puisse
dire
c'est que l'ambiance était au rendez
vous
[Musique]
12 hop éphémère pour douze morceaux du
répertoire pop-rock français
international 45 adhérents du projet
tous en scène de l'association multi
sont fait vibrer la salle de la tour de
voisins-le-bretonneux tous ont leur
spécialité
[Musique]
en fait on choisit les morceaux et
viennent se greffer dessus en fait les
musiciens qui ont envie de participer à
telle ou telle autre morceau tout
simplement
[Musique]
quasiment tous plus ou moins bien ce qui
est bien c'est que ça change avec chaque
personne et une fin avec chaque chanson
il ya une atmosphère différente et c'est
ce qui rend le la musique encore
meilleur et le ressenti je pense
l'association multi sont deux voisins
retenu existe depuis cinq ans avec ce
projet elle permet à des amateurs de
développer leurs compétences musicales
auprès des professionnels
l'objectif c'est de découvrir
l'instrument de l'approché de le
pratiquer de jouer ensemble et de se
produire sur scène
invité par l'association le groupe
illinois eden rock animé la deuxième
partie sur les tubes des rolling stones
noël est terminée c'est l'heure du bilan
pour les distributeurs de jouets pour en
savoir plus nous sommes allés chez
asmodée basé à guyancourt une autre à
une entreprise notamment connu pour le
jeu doble ou encore jungle speed
un reportage de michael et demi d'euros
jungle speed les loups garous de
thiercelieux ou encore time's up des
licences que vous avez peut-être
retrouvé au pied du sapin cette année
derrière ces jeux à succès l'entreprise
à ce mode est basé à guyancourt et pour
elle les jeux de société ont toujours la
cote à noëlle giret 60% du chiffre
d'affaires se fait sur les 3 trois
derniers mois où effectivement on voit
les grosses tendances se dégagent et
quand numéro un du jeu qui reste
incontournable pour l'instant ne serait
ce que sur la le jeu pardon de base
c'est joe boyd a continué à bien
performer c'est numéro un des ventes
toutes catégories dans le jeu on parle
de plus de deux cent mille copies
vendues par ont rejoints rien que cette
année en france 20 millions de boîtes de
jeux ont été vendus depuis 2011 d'après
ndp group spécialiste des études de
marché
en l'espace de 20 ans à ce mode et s'est
imposé comme l'un des leaders européens
de la distribution de jeux de société
dans ses écuries on retrouve également
les jeux de cartes à collectionner et
cette année encore pokémon a raflé la
mise parce qu'on est aussi le
distributeur donc le pokémon en france
et avec le phénomène pokémon go qui ne
va permis effectivement de donner encore
un coup de lumière sur cette très belle
licence qui était déjà très forte ce
qu'on attend c'est parfois l'oublier
mais pokemon reste toujours depuis 20
ans une licence assez forte dans le jeu
de cartes à collectionner 95% du jeu de
cartes
en france c'est ma nuque brisée par un
pokémon chaque année l'enseigne
distribué dit 200 nouveautés
de quoi déjà donné des idées au père
noël pour 2017
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de nous
avoir suivis et surtout bonne soirée
[Musique]